hey guys i'm lauren zima and i am here
in defense of Bethenny Frankel here's
the thing people hang on Bethenny they
say she's to me here's why they're wrong
Bethenny is the best person on reality
TV at not committing the ultimate
reality sin what is it not owning it
Bethenny owns it everything she does
owns it owns it owns it call someone a
[ __ ] owns it call someone a horn owns it
can Bethenny be a little mean yes but
the thing is she's honest okay on a
reality TV show what makes things
interesting drama you need it and
Bethenny's honesty brings a lot of drama
that's why I watch she's also really
freaking funny I understand that
sometimes people are the butter for
jokes but still funny and here's the
thing people might say that Bethenny is
to mean but I truly believe she's a good
friend at the end of the day I believe
she'd be there for every single one of
the other housewives she's talked about
that the fact that they've been on this
journey together and yes they might
fight Bethenny is also super vulnerable
we've seen her go through so many
struggles on the show he have seen her
cry we have seen her crying bathroom
floors we have seen her cry in the back
of limousines we have seen her cry and
tropical islands and I'm right there
with you Bethenny so people hate on
Bethenny for her products for her brand
here's the thing Bethenny is all about a
working hard as a woman and setting a
great example for women in business I
don't care if she brings her brand on
the show it's alcohol what fuels great
fights on the housewives alcohol she has
brought some of the most amazing moments
in real housewives history I'm talking
about scary Island go to sleep go to
sleep you're crazy that's what i tell
myself every night Bethenny Frankel
thank you for being a woman who supports
women for being a great example and for
owning it now go to sleep but guys
here's the thing i might be a Bethenny
defender are you I want to know let me
know on Twitter and be sure to subscribe
to our YouTube channel we have many
things to defend and discuss